das hier ist der beste und schnellste KL
den du jemals essen wirst und du isst
nicht pure Mayo und Zucker zunächst
einmal halbieren wir unseren
Kohl dann viteln wir
ihn nächster step Mandoline draufsetzen
und ab geht's und fertig geschnibbelt ab
in der Schüssel dann können wir auch
schon salzen dann einmal durchwerfen und
dann können wir auch einfach anfangen
unsere restlichen Zutaten hinzuugeben
Mayo darf bei einem guten col nicht
fehlen dann benötigen wir eine
biozitrone und Zitrone Essen und jetzt
Knoblauch Zehen und reiben erstmal eine
dann schauen wir weiter ein bisschen
Chili einfach für den Kick und dann eine
Zutat fehlt noch ein bisschen
Frühlingszwiebel auch die geben wir noch
hinzu und dann können wir auch anfangen
das Ganze einmal schön durchzukneten
einfach mit den Händen rich ordentlich
zusammendrücken macht sich perfekt auf
Sandwiches guck mal wie saftig der ist
den kann man jetzt entweder über Nacht
marinieren lassen oder einfach direkt
essen wenn man ungedüldig ist so wie ich